let me start by saying so is this listen
obviously I loved your guys's chemistry
in ragnerok you have fantastic chemistry
in this is this the beginning of you
guys doing like a boggart but all kind
of we talk yeah we talked about it I was
certainly a reference point for me I
thought of all those grades but called
Bogart Hepburn Tracy
you know we used to do that used to be
able to see actors for decades you know
joining each other it's fun to see
someone through the breadth of their
career work with someone else and
stretching those ways so I wouldn't be
mad at it you know you're on the set of
this are you already thinking looking at
these scripts do you know what I mean
like is it something look if that makes
any sense
who was it I guess what I'm saying is it
have you already looked at other things
or is it something if it magically comes
to follow - for us - yeah yeah we look
at it you maybe when you're reading a
script you and having worked together
before just being great friends makes
the whole process easy I think the more
you work you kind of you really
appreciate the ones that have fun and
really kind of lower the experiences
that aren't and that has to do with the
people we don't need and and you're four
months in each other space and you know
the kind of it's it's such a sort of
small little tight unit you know and you
want to be with people you appreciate
and appreciate you and there's a trust
and respect and so yeah there's a couple
of things a lot of actors have spoken do
you have like a pre shooting ritual some
people love music some people love
silence whatever it may be
how did each of you work and is it
something that it's like super
compatible or are you more unique why I
don't have a pre ritual if you have one
ritual but I'm not gonna say what it is
but I it's a ritual I've adopted really
we we have different approaches I think
but similar approaches we've kind of
melded our punches heavily yeah yeah we
learn from each other I kind of I I like
to just sort of scare the hell out of me
you know and improv sort of is
intimidating but I cut it becomes an
addictive sort of adrenalin and then
like I kind of love it you know and but
it needs to be reined in from beyond
like anything that matters it's good
there you casually come with me off the
way it's a dance I understand I have a
few random questions which I'm gonna try
to work in really quick do you have do
you remember your first movie or TV show
crush Robin wrought in princess broad oh
yeah I like Uncle Jesse Hulka also and
this was hard for me on Ragnarok one of
my earliest crushes is Jeff Goldblum Wow
so that was I was that was that still is
that's yeah you can't go wrong I think
it's my last thing what TV show would
you love to guest star on mmm peaky
blinders
yeah both quality entertainment thank
you so much for your time thank you
enjoy the afternoon